on sourit valérie cadette 46 dans ce
teaser chocolatées
[Musique]
mais
je suis confiseur chocolatier
je produis des matières premières sur le
terrain d'îles en mer et avec ces
matières premières je crée mes recettes
ou le perpétuent la tradition donc les
produits que je fais sont à base de gala
b enfin gala dès que je produis si
amazon de roupies d'une route que je
produis ici à base de feuilles de 4
épices à base de curcuma base de
gingembre mangue également alors je
comprendrais catégorie produits pays
parce qu'il ya deux produits qui
représentent la tradition la plus pure
de la réunion à savoir le gala dès que
je fais moi même et les bonbons la route
à est en fait ces biscuits et cette
confusion ils sont c'est mon
traditionnel qu'il devienne une rare à
la réunion
avant j'étais directeur financier dans
des cliniques et en 2016
j'ai fait une reconversion
professionnelle vers un métier passion
et j'ai passé mon cap2 confiseur
chocolatier donc pour créer mon
entreprise je me suis appuyé sur le
dispositif pôle emploi qui accompagne
les créateurs d'entreprise pendant les
deux années où j'ai fait de la r&d j'ai
cherché mon réseau parce que j'ai créés
tous à partir de rien être chef
d'entreprise c'est une grande autonomie
cela dit c'est pas ça le plus important
le plus important c'est de faire des
choses que l'on aime
mettre tout son coeur et moi ce que je
voulais c'était faire figurer la
tradition c'est j'ai créé mon entreprise
à la réunion parce que je voulais faire
du gala des et je voulais faire de la
route et je voulais les produire moi mes
mains et pouvoir transmettre plus par un
[Musique]
je vais gagner le challenge les
créateurs dans la catégorie produits
pays car je considère que mes produits
le long de la route et le gala d un
représentant par excellence le coeur de
la tradition réunionnaise a gagné c'est
les remettre en lumière et il le mérite
a bonjour je m'appelle martin potins
chez 38 ans et je suis présidente de
réunir hommes
alors réuni rome est une société qui
produit des rhums arrangés des roms fait
avec du rhum traditionnel de la réunion
et des produits issus de l'agriculture
réunionnaise
tout est fait à la main il n'y a pas de
machines de la découpe du fruit à la
mise en bouteille
tout est fait vraiment artisanalement
s'est fait sans colorant ni conservateur
et c'est vraiment le fruit qui donne la
couleur à la bouteille le concours dans
la catégorie produits pays en a plus de
150 références de rome et tous sont
issus de fruits provenant de la réunion
surtout la nasse viennent des champs de
mes parents puisque mais mes parents
sont agriculteurs et maison qu'aussi
avant de créer mon entreprise j'ai été
assistant de gestion et j'ai poursuivi
sur une activité de commercial
j'ai fini mon contrat j'ai décidé par la
suite de lancer mon entreprise j'ai créé
mon entreprise avec mes fonds propres
que voilà je me suis lancé tout seul
alors être chef d'entreprise c'est
d'abord avoir sa société mettre en avant
ses idées défendre son produit je fais
beaucoup les salons surtout le salon art
culture et la fois paris est montré
là sa propre création issue de la
culture réunionnaise c'est quelque chose
de formidable
l'entreprise a connu une expansion très
rapide maintenant l'ambition c'est de
viser le marché international c'étaient
les états unis ou la chine
je vais gagner le prix du produit pays
car mon produit est issu de la culture
réunionnaise
il met en avant le savoir faire local et
les matières premières sont issus à 100%
de l'agriculture réunionnaise est
essentiellement familial etc le rhum
arrangé aux 208 médaille
[Musique]